so the other thing that ancient
Egyptians used often to protect tombs
was magic right that's the fundamental
ideas of their religion and the curses
on tombs come in a variety of different
levels so sometimes they can be very
soft or gentle like if you do something
bad God will judge you in the afterlife
I'm sure that any you know nefarious
tomb robber wouldn't have taken that to
heart too much or already knew that
before he entered the tomb
the average ancient Egyptian did not
find tomb curses to be you know a
deterrent because first of all we don't
have many curses that have been
preserved and second of all uh they're
still being robbed clearly the benefits
outweighed the potential
threats
even in the afterlife and we have to
remember that not all Egyptians
believed in an afterlife we do have
texts that show that those you know some
people who are pessimistic and who
questioned was there
actually an afterlife tomb curses were
um were certainly uh utilized more with
a wish than a than a belief uh I don't
think there's much question about that
in fact most of the Tomb curses we have
you know come from the Old Kingdom and
they stop doing them
so when we get into things like tootin
Commons tomb right everybody thinks that
there was a curse on King of Tut's tomb
but there wasn't what we do have is
within the burial chamber you have these
four things called the protective
magical bricks and they go in the four
corners the north the southeast and the
west and essentially they're a magical
spell that generically protect from
anything bad happening from the four
cardinal directions but there's no or
else Clause right so what does actually
protect these two so unfortunately they
did not have the booby traps or giant
rolling Boulders that you see in Indiana
Jones I know I want them to be real you
want them to be real they are not real
but what they do have is still very cool
what they have are giant stone blocks
called portcullis stones and these are
made of very hard Stone so essentially
they're giant plugs that are not meant
to be moved by anybody and honestly no
normal person can move one of those
stones those stones need to be moved by
stone masons who have real knowledge of
how to cut into them not just anybody
can break into this
the coolest tomb to ever try to protect
against tomb robbing is the tomb of
sunwazareth III at abidus
and this thing's amazing because synonym
III basically reconceptualized the
entire tomb to try to protect it so the
first thing that he did was he moved his
tomb back to abidus a place where Kings
hadn't been buried for a thousand years
hundreds of miles away from where the
modern kings are being buried so nobody
would ever expect that he was actually
buried there right so the next thing
that he does is that he abandons the
pyramid because the pyramid is a giant
marker of where your tomb is and instead
he's buried within a mountain where the
mountain manages to act like the
pyramidal symbol and the entrance into
his tomb was through about 40 feet of
loose sand so in order to get to the
entrance you have to move all this sand
and that is a giant sand moving
operation that leaves a massive hole
over several you know weeks if not
months that somebody in the town is
supposed to see even once you find the
entrance to the tomb there are two
passageways that are about eight feet
wide Square each that kind of like lead
into each other
and even then you get into the inside
where you have here no you small pole
vault chamber with like three little
rooms and you think oh well this is it
right no that's where you get the next
port color stone hidden in the ceiling
that you can't see so you have to remove
the veneer find a giant Granite port
color stone get your stone masons to
take that out at that point you can then
go down the chamber where there is a
massive drop 15 meters straight down
again needing to move sand or getting a
giant ladder and at the bottom of the
pit that's where your hidden door is and
then you go 15 meters straight up again
to find the next hidden entrance within
the tomb itself again behind veneer so
the tomb robbers once they get to this
location they see this massive pork
collar Stone hidden in the top they'd
remove the veneer but then they saw that
it wasn't just one
it was in fact a series of nine so it
was easier instead of moving each of
these nine to dig an opposite tunnel
that kind of follows around through the
Limestone to get into the next passage
once they get into the next passage you
then have this incredibly long curving
chamber that goes through the
Mountainside so they ran down to the end
of that
where there was nothing and so they
start ripping out all the walls again
taking off the veneer again like where's
the next hidden block where is it where
is it they can't find it so they move
backwards and they move backwards and
they move backwards for all of that
length and massive amount of stone
veneer removed until finally they found
sin was with the third sarcophagus
halfway in the middle of this chamber
right on the other side of the nine
block stones and even his particular
sarcophagus managed to have this last
locking mechanism that they had to break
open and yet they still managed to do it
his tomb was robbed within 100 to 150
years during the second intermediate
period but you have to imagine the
amount of people the amount of Labor
that went into this this isn't just a
couple of guys this is the local
Administration bringing in workforces
specifically to be able to Rob this tomb
nobody else would have been able to do
it thank you
the New Kingdom was a period where Egypt
is forging an enormous Empire and that's
an Empire to the South and Nubia and to
the north in the Levant and it is the
period of Egypt's greatest wealth so the
kings of the New Kingdom were as wealthy
as the Egyptians ever were the Kiss of
the New Kingdom did have very rich
burials the sad thing is is that we
simply don't have the burial Goods you
know that they were robbed in Antiquity
they've been robbed probably they were
probably robbed for centuries so
simply by the size the sheer magnitude
of these tombs they must have been
absolutely Splendid so then we move into
the New Kingdom right this is the time
of Empire and it's the time of most of
the Pharaohs that you've heard of people
like hatchips
Ramses the Great and these guys are all
buried in the Valley of the Kings and
the Pharaohs who created the initial
Valley of the Kings either amen hotep
the first or two Moses the first
somebody in there
reconceptualized this place to be a
totally hidden cemetery and it wasn't
just the cemetery their entire town of
Craftsman the people at Daryl Medina
were supposed to be hidden the problem
is is you can't actually hide all that I
mean the Valley of the Kings is in
thieves it's a major city this type of
secret cannot be kept right and then the
one thing that I cannot explain
is that they decided to change the
actual effective mechanism that was
protecting them they decided to stop
using these giant port color stones and
instead use mud brick and gravel which I
could probably take out given a shovel
in enough time and that changes the
scale of Tomb robbing
inevitably right you no longer need
hundreds or dozens of people with
specialized knowledge no instead a group
of five to ten guys could do this on
their own at night with a couple of
shovels what ends up happening are small
groups of people actually end up making
this a side hustle and we have these
really cool judicial records called the
tomb robbery papyri that actually give
us details about some of these guys and
what they're doing and they'll say
things like we go out as a regular habit
to actually dig into the tombs and one
of these particular stories end up
telling us that in order to get all of
the metal and semi-precious stones that
are physically wrapped into a mummy one
of the things that they do is they light
The Mummy on fire so that they can then
like loosen all this stuff and grab it
quickly the problem is is that when you
light a mummy on fire you are destroying
the afterlife of the deceased
so these guys are no longer on trial for
theft or destruction of property or
breaking and entering no they're on
trial for murder and if it's a king
they're on trial for regicide if your
body is destroyed and your name is
destroyed that's pretty bad for the
deceased that's why a lot of times tombs
had images had statues of themselves had
their names everywhere so let's say
something does happen to your body right
okay well you can still live on because
this this image of you somewhere
your name is still somewhere
it's probably not fair that the objects
from tarant have totally overshadowed
other tomb discoveries but it's
impossible not to acknowledge that we've
learned more from that one nearly intact
tomb than we've learned from all the
other tombs in terms of goods probably
all put together
I don't think that we would be nearly as
knowledgeable
about what the Egyptians did produce
for the burial of a ruler if we didn't
have the tomb of Tut so it's hard not to
give it its due
when Carter found the Tomb in November
1922 the tomb was not untouched
basically it had been robbed twice
probably during the reign of hormet and
what's interesting is that they only got
into the anti-chamber you know the first
chamber they did not get into the burial
chamber nor did they get into the
treasury which was off of the burial
chamber and you even find objects that
they let go you know in the corridor on
the way out of the tomb which makes us
think that they were discovered by
police that happened to be policing the
Kings Valley
a lot of his boxes have all of their
locks broken off of them uh if you look
at his bow and arrow set there seemed to
be like dirty footprints actually
walking up the side of it all of his
jars have been unstopped and looked into
and even his famous Golden Throne that
had Gold Leaf foil on it the bottom fret
work was ripped out but if you compare
the anti-chamber to the treasury you see
the treasury it's full but it's nice and
neat that room was never broken into
he had umbrellas he had gloves he had
socks
these are things that we don't get in
other burials we might get them ripped
up
and maybe guess what they are and then
in addition just to visit and see what
Carter saw when he first opened there
and the oars
for the boat that carries him across the
sky are laid out in a ritual pattern on
the floor I'm you know this is untouched
right so
there's just I mean you could go on and
on all day long and I'm afraid
the fortunate thing is that Tutankhamun
was so insignificant that at some level
he was actually forgotten about that
information security wasn't as much of a
problem for him and when we get to 150
to 200 years later when we have Ramses
the sixth tomb Ramsay's the sixth then
decides to build his tomb just above
Tut's tomb in the same Mountainside and
so as they're hewing out the tomb and
taking all the stone out they're just
throwing it on top of tuts further
burying him below where he then actually
did Lay hidden until 1922. was two donk
almonds tomb richer
or less Rich than other kings of the
18th Dynasty now we know the 18th
dynasty was their empire building time
these are incredibly wealthy pharaohs if
we did have one more earlier tomb that
was near intact and we could judge what
we don't have
[Music]
so you might think that you know based
on these stories that there were no
honest officials in ancient Egypt but
that is not true actually most of them a
lot of them must have been honest and at
the very end of the New Kingdom
beginning of the third intermediate
period the priesthood of Amun has
essentially taken over the city and
there's one guy by the name of penagem
II who decides that this is too much so
pentagem II realizes that he cannot
protect the actual tombs of the Kings
but he still wants to protect their
afterlives so what he does is he takes a
small group of people in the dead of
night he opens up the individual tombs
which he had records for because he's in
charge and he takes out the actual
bodies of the Pharaohs and he removes
all the bodies and moves them around to
the other side of the hill and buries
them in an actual secret tomb that later
ended up being called the Daryl bakri
cache in 1881 this Daryl bakri cache was
eventually found the Egyptians actually
made a movie about it in 1969 called el
mumia the night of the counting of the
years what is found by specific family
that then decided to
take things slowly out of the Tomb and
sell them and the local officials
realized that somebody had found
something really special somebody had
found a tomb that was connected to the
actual pharaohs and eventually what ends
up happening is the officials find the
tomb they managed to take out the
objects and bring it all to Cairo to put
inside the museum that's why when you go
into the national museum of Egyptian
civilization today you can actually look
at Ramses the Great you can look at
Moses III and you can see the glory of
the past we have all of their
Irreplaceable knowledge because the
officials today protected it
[Music]
thank you